one man is dead tonight after a shooting  in North Las Vegas this happened around  4 30 this afternoon near Craig and  Simmons Madison Kimbrough joins us live  there tonight with the latest details  Madison  the shooting took place just after 4 15  this afternoon take a look as it's still  an active scene right here on San Miguel  and Coleman here in North Las Vegas well  it's unclear what led up to the shooting  we do know a man in his 20s is now dead  North Las Vegas has not released any  other details about the male victim or  who else was involved in the shooting  the public is asked to use alternate  routes if coming to this area as you can  see this roadway is currently  to avoid the area and try to go an  alternate route like I just mentioned  all right reporting live Madison  Kimbrough 8 News Now